hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of our forum leaders GT who is
asking about search engine optimization
for Yahoo and Bing and is it worth the
effort or not so GT I can tell you what
we do here most of our traffic comes
from google so ninety percent of our
search engine traffic comes from google
so we don't really spend a lot of time
focusing on yahoo and bing now most of
the optimization techniques are going to
be the same regardless so you don't have
to spend a lot of time necessarily
focusing on the other search engines you
still need quality content you still
need on-site optimization you still need
to have links come into your site there
may be some slight nuances and
differences between them and how I would
judge if you should spend that time or
not is to look at your analytics and see
where you're getting traffic from so if
you are seeing that you get traffic from
yahoo and bing do a quick search for
those keywords that your ranking for and
see where you're writing for it so if
you know a keyword is giving you traffic
from yahoo go to yahoo do the search and
see where you come up if you're at the
bottom of page one or on page two or
further down that could be a significant
opportunity to do some optimization to
get higher ranked so you know you're
getting traffic from what already and if
you were on you know one two or three
instead of very similar on page two or
three then that could be an opportunity
to get a lot more traffic if you do the
search annuity number one or two then
you're not going to be able to really
get a huge return on that investment
that you put into your efforts because
you're already ranking at the top so I
hope that helps again we do that same
process for for google if we see that
you know we're ranking you know number
ten or on page 24 keyword that's
generating traffic then maybe it's worth
spending some extra effort to optimize
it to get closer to the one two or three
position so we can get more traffic
that's what we do I hope that helps GT
if you guys liked the video please give
a thumbs up or a
a comment below I love hearing you guys
have to say makes me want to do more of
these videos so you know please make
sure to leave some feedback and
hopefully we'll see you in the next
episode
you